when I look at these days
Wow stun so easy really I'm talking
sometimes I think about my old days so
stupid why I'm Joan of the building
laughs like this day when I watch like a
spider-man and Superman and Iron Man Wow
just I I rather I rather I rather I'm a
Jackie Chan boy in the US and the US
starts so so easy
really I just every time I watch that
the spider-man you sold and cut cotton
cotton cotton come back as a Wow right
just like the Iron Man so you can you
eat you cha the old day we'd have to do
everything ourselves you have to jump
that high you come and bring your anger
you bring your finger and you have to
say nothing yeah I'm okay then yeah what
can you do if you get hurt if you get
hurt you just like you never come to
work again lie lie lie under the under
the Dragon I fight with boots Lee better
have a pal you one stick right here I
did pull my down then I lie down I see
Bruce Lee ladies turn around and cut he
just throw the to stick run there's so
many stuntmen
he just run to me and pull me up I'm
sorry sorry
then suppose er what can I do is done
guy always get hurt but after you come
to sorry
I pretend hurt but it is a hurt you know
my I was SWAT swallowed here then then
the whole dying the whole night whatever
you go watching me that's it then
except when he turned around I sometimes
do this and that's how boost look know
me and that's how me will be coming a
friend yeah yeah very lucky it's
fascinating to watch different fighting
styles on the screen and to watch how
styles develop and trademarks form and
and a career is built you know your
style changed through the years and now
very much we know what the Jackie Chan
style is what I I really I spend more
than what two or three years to change
my style and that time everybody know
after Bruce Lee died as so many boos Lee
whose life was table booze chair Oh
Bruce and even I you and I'm making a
movie I'm I'm first time and the
director call me up with a telegram
telegram we don't have a telephone and
that we have telegram I get there oh
they invite me back to Hong Kong to make
a film and I so hard to make a film
first time I have my own poster I don't
even I don't even see my name second you
know second pawsley Jackie Chan and I
outside that's here there are all the
people
Wow push lino movie it's not I don't
even see my name no just but you you
have to listen the director what you do
you have to do this Wow
and yelling yeah ah
I said no I'm not this kind of person
okay could you do that for about five
know the whole thing who wants to see it
come on I I said I'm not this kind of
person and the audience they don't buy
these kind of things I'm too young and I
was like I was 18 and 19 years old I'm
doing just not me and I spent two years
to make this kind of movie and nobody go
to Seattle to see it you were better
than Bruce table though no later on
later on I said how like different than
Bruce Lee then slowly I with my friend
I'll start going it and with what you
push me okay push Lee kick high kick low
after boo sleep like this I I do this
and later on it I said everybody said
Jackie just be yourself I said myself
okay then you see the movie inside just
myself and slowly and suddenly my movie
comes out and sneaking ego shadow boom
big hit why because outside there's so
many every people who do this then I
accept Jackie Chan and the audience
hahaha
then becoming a different so from now at
that time I said okay I always want the
different than some other people so just
one when you see the fighting sequence I
always could graph all of them different
than some other people